so this next story from vice I haven't
actually read it
why I quit being a climate activists the
climate movement is overwhelmingly white
so I walked away so so the white people
they're trying to save the planet we
must stop it
this is actually a common thread we've
seen a lot like there's a mean in this
where it says what's the meme it's like
damn white people on their you know
poles karna have hat polite children
yeah yeah like so there's there's a meme
about this where you name it there is an
article ragging on white people for
doing it too many firefighters are white
damn white people in their polls Nate
polls card out of bag trying to save
people from fires so this is a meme well
like it's a commonly occurring thing so
I wanted I wanted to read a little bit
and see what your reaction is now I will
say every one of these stories has a
smidgen of truth to them like
criticizing people for not supporting
certain causes okay but for some reason
it's about the color of their skin which
I never quite understood yeah too many
people who want to save the planet are
white that's why I'm quitting the thing
is they don't want to save the planet
you never did you just don't like white
people yeah I know a holes that are all
different skin colors and I know really
cool people that are all different skin
colors it's so silly I don't have people
yeah we're all different I know exactly
it's like if there's people of all
different types of person of all
different ethnicities like oh so race
thing is so silly to me well so this is
why it's I thought this would be fun
because you know I read this stuff all
day every day you but you don't know
don't so I'd like to get a genuine
reaction from you as you enter this
world of man white people are bad all
right so let's let's let's read a little
bit they start by saying oh what's this
I feel tired when my stories are used
for inspiration but I'm not wanted in
the room for negotiations what is that
no no no no great start great great in
2013 typhoon Haiyan battered Southeast
Asia killing 6300 people in the
Philippines alone the three-story the
three-story surge rolled over parts of
the city of Tacloban hitting my family's
neighborhood the hardest schools that
were designed storm shelter schools that
were designated storm shelters and
tombed those taking refuge from the
rising waters my aunt like many women in
the Philippines a country made above
7,000 I
can't swim she my uncle and my cousin
were missing or presumed dead hey man
look I mean the sincerely I feel for you
I empathize I'm sorry this is happening
and that's why I I do like to fight for
the environment and that's why I would
never give up on a cause of doing our
best just because too many white people
want to do it too well where did it get
to that part and how does that even make
sense oh I know I know right we'll get
to it I'm just saying like listen man if
you're willing to abandon saving the
planet because you don't like white
people I don't think you ever actually
wanted to save the planet yeah I think
you just darling
I think you're right I think you're
racist yeah they say she goes on we only
found out they survived that's good
after three grief ridden days from a
family member who had made his way
through the gravich province with the
military their home in the fish farm
they depended on for their livelihood
were devastated and they still haven't
fully recovered as a climate activists
in Berlin I felt required to tell my
Filipino family's experience during
speeches and rallies because this form
of storytelling was the only thing that
would move a vastly white European
audience to an emotional response and
climate urgency even though it was
exhausting telling the story especially
since any mention of hurricanes the news
gives me anxiety I'm gonna stop right
there as much as I'd like to give you
respect because it's a tragedy you're
gonna have to figure out how to get past
being anxious over someone saying a word
I mean that sincerely like if you're
gonna do this is an activist and someone
says hurricane you start feeling anxiety
maybe that's why you should not do this
hmm that is exposure therapy and the
more you hear the word hurricane as
scary as it is the first few times the
easier it's gonna get well then good
work then good that she's not running
away from her I would hear great speech
so emotional when your voice cracked but
after a while I realized I would only be
called upon when climate organizations
need an inspiring story or a diverse
voice context for a campaign or to
participate in a workshop for fun when
everyone else on the all-white project
was getting paid well now she's starting
actually I'm sorry to empathize with her
yeah but here's the problem it sounds
like so far it's not that they're white
it's that they're racists who pretend
not to be racists and tokenize her right
to me it sounds like she's not working
for one of these campaigns it sounds
like she's a volunteer well there you go
well but what about her quitting being
an activist because too many white
people you know mean yeah whenever I
would question the whiteness of these
spaces and how strategies didn't take
race into account I would be met with
uncomfortable silences the last time at
a nationwide movement building workshop
last April I was asked well then why are
you even here okay right well are these
people even trying to save the
environment like it sounds like it's a
it's an organization she saw like people
are just trying to like make themselves
look good by acting to be activists this
is awesome because Adam what we all know
this yeah but you're exploring and
undiscoverable coming to the right
that's what it sounds like yes called
virtue signaling where people pretend to
care about and love activists issues
people show it all the time so she's
getting mad that they won't bend to what
she demands they Bend - they're mad
because they refuse to bend to what she
wants them to bend to and both are like
why are you even here accusing each
other of not being the real activists
right there's no there's no right way to
do this activism I think the reality is
they've tried casting a big net over
everything and you can't some things
don't mesh some you you can't educate
for exactly
you can't simultaneously advocate for a
real Abrahamic religion and the LGBT
community when the Abrahamic religion is
fundamentalist they do right now in
Birmingham I don't know if you know this
a bunch of Maat right now but in the
past several months
hmm a school was doing an LGBTQ
curriculum teaching kids about you know
LGBTQ issues okay Muslims protested it
okay but according to like
intersectionality they're both oppressed
groups so which are pressed group takes
precedent that's a good question well in
my opinion I don't think your religion
should should you know but the challenge
then is should the school be teaching
something well I don't know man
they're that they're these these
activists were complaining that the
Muslims were upset because the school is
teaching their kids as young as seven
years old about adult you know
relationships I feel like that falls in
line with sex education right in a sense
you know it's like in NCH years when
you're trying to figure out all
stuff like you should be talking about
seven years old seven years old feels
too young right and so that was actually
one of the big complaints I mean you're
not putting a seven-year-old in sex
education that's what they were doing no
that seems a little too young well
whatever your opinion that might be
right the issue is that like what we're
seeing here with this this you know
climate activists is that they try to
cast a big enough tent to be like you
know Muslims are an oppressed group and
so is LGBTQ community and then they may
there's a painting of a woman wearing a
rainbow hijab okay but in the Middle
East that is like they do horrible
things to people who do stuff like that
yeah I mean it doesn't it doesn't
actually make even women still right oh
yeah totally I can't even drive yeah
well let's get back to climate activism
well too much sure sure she said so I
decided not to be there anymore after
four years of helping organize direct
actions speeches workshops and countless
video calls I started hiding and
declining requests I was burned out I
felt guilty like I was letting my people
down but I also felt let down by the
lack of support when I had gone to the
streets I stopped talking to people who
didn't relate including friends who are
telling me to come join them now that
the marches were becoming more popular I
was also in bed sick a lot I stayed at
home from climate marches telling people
my knee was injured and kept myself
needing to regain all the energy I'd put
into organizing even being present
doesn't always mean being seen or heard
last week Ugandan activist Vanessa
Nakata found herself cropped from a
picture and dialogue as the only African
on a youth panel in the Davos World
Economic Forum she said the erasure
showed how we are valued now let me tell
you something I can actually understand
where she's coming from yeah i'ma throw
it to good ol greta toon burger
privileged white wealthy telling poor
people how to live right so you've got
looks actually start from their premise
of white privilege white people tend to
be wealthy or have better access then
why are you going to the poorest people
and saying cut off your heat and cut off
your electricity no fuels for you guess
who's not gonna be hurt by that Greta
and her family yeah they're though yeah
right the rich the wealthy privileged
elites who fly around on private jets
acting like they're doing the right
thing
rules for thee but not for me right so I
can I can actually sympathize a lot of
these act
two vests and the you know the the the
progressive types they tend to be
wealthy college-educated white and she's
upset with them so you know what
I guess if she if she was to focus on
the ideology not the race yeah I'd
actually agree but I think she becomes
you know wrong when she gets blaming the
fact that it's too many white people
many other climate activists of color
have described similar experiences of
tokenism Maori and disability rights
campaigner Cara Sherwood Oh Reagan found
that as an indigenous person at the UN
climate conferences organisers would
suggest showing support and passing the
mic but the same people would be the
ones taking up space in negotiations and
speaking to media at the same time
because I am Filipino German and look
ethnically ambiguous it's hard for me to
empathize the urgency or danger of
climate activism as a Filipina I am
German too after all similar to what
Colombian American climate activists
Jamie Margolin said my presence quote
towed a line between inclusion and
exclusion so why what why is this
happening why is that these activists
are fighting each other and accusing
each other of the exact same things I
don't know nothing's even happening
feels like they're getting jaded because
they're trying and they're focusing on
the wrong issues and everyone is
focusing on the wrong issues not just
them but like the the white people
they're referring to they're also not no
one's actually really doing anything for
the climate you know it's like they're
just complaining about you thinking
about each other like here you're not
doing this the way we think you should
be doing it and like everyone's saying
that and then what is actually being
done here's my here's my theory here's
what I think
Greta Greta wrote an op-ed where she
said it's it's not really about the
environment it's about ending
colonialism and patriarchy and
capitalism remember that she wrote that
op-ed it was on some website and I think
that actually that's actually it so if
you're a person of color who actually
thinks these people can be honest with
you about the environment you show up
and they're talking about some other
random stuff you're like will you talk
you're not even talking about what just
happened in the Philippines you know why
they're not talking about what happened
to the Philippines to your family
because they're trying to end patriarchy
and capitalism they don't care about the
environment right that's why they say
things like we need to dramatically
change the gut the economy to socialism
and then you're like what if we just
don't invest it in nuclear energy and
you know electric cars well actually
actually hybrid cars are actually worse
we win a story on that one but we didn't
uh we didn't pull that one up
yeah actually I'll mention this real
quick electric cars hybrid cars are
worse for the environment because
they're heavier so they put three times
worse because they're heavier and people
aren't charging them so they're often
just guzzling gas
what do you mean charging them like I
have a hybrid and you don't have to plug
them in well what did the story say it's
like they're like the full electric
vehicles no no hybrid cars apparently
the story was that they're they're
failing to take care of them properly
and run them properly you don't have to
plug them in they're not plug them in I
don't know what the story was another
pulled up so but they were saying that
because there have yours of the
batteries that they end up emitting more
carbon in the production and whatever or
so you just call them plug-in hybrid
cars which makes sense so let's let's
let's see what her conclusion here is
she says as shear Widow Reagan said Oh
whatever we need to feel respected and
feel valued in our climate activism
until the rest of the movement
understands that our stories may also
provide solutions I'm sharing my
activism on my own terms so let's all
wrap this one up and no one jumps in
with some of the chat but I think the
problem as I stated already this the way
she's framing it about white people
yeah is a really good example of why
it's so hard to actually work with them
and why she's having trouble because the
problem is really that she's surrounded
by fake activists right who don't really
care they don't care and that instead of
addressing the fact that they're fake
activists she goes they're white so what
do you thinks gonna happen know that
when she goes out and says this and then
you trying go to a white person they're
gonna be like I think you just don't
like white people that's what it sounds
like yeah like you don't actually like
if she or the few white people that she
was involved with are not very good
people in general it has nothing to do
with their race they're just not good
people
well congratulations Adam you are now a
bigot of course with internalized white
supremacy but what am i sense is
heteronormative patriarchy is teaching
man yeah no it's like as I said there's
a holes everywhere but they don't make
that they don't understand she can't see
past their race she doesn't understand
they're lying to you there
tending their virtue signaling yeah
they're trying to put a token on there
to further themselves to make themselves
did you see what people did nah I don't
get too political but I'm gonna do it at
his rally he had a row of black people
standing behind him that's a just one
row well there's a buncha people behind
him uh-huh
but in the front row right behind him in
the crowd was all black people right and
everyone immediate was like dude we know
what you're doing like what is this
you're trying to make it a final thing
you try it right yeah barnes and noble
decided to do diversity bookcovers to be
woke and the woke attacked them for it
so they're fake activists they pulled it
off yeah you don't say look I want to
sympathize with this woman but I kind of
feel like she's a fake activist too
yeah it's like you know Pride Week in
New York every single store was like a
rainbow and I have you know that I err I
have lots of friends in that community I
love them all they're all great people
you know and you know I support them but
it felt like everyone was just jumping
on the bandwagon because that's what was
that's the clickbait thing you know it's
like exactly it that's what it is right
singling Vern actually care oh look how
fortunate we are it's like no you know
you're not you just want people to come
and shop in your store like come on
sorry hey that and I would actually want
to come shop in your store more thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you